can i ask about the uh
silence of the lambs bit how long were
you in that room for i seemed like 20
minutes to a half hour maybe it seemed
like or i don't know for sure but that's
what it seemed like and it was like you
were it was pretty [ __ ] scary right
like really bad yeah the most
traumatizing thing i mean you couldn't
see you couldn't see anything like your
hand in front of your face or what like
you might as well not have eyes for one
thing and that's scary and then and then
just like the not knowing what you're
like how far are these guys you know
these guys are kind of dumb to our
bosses sometimes they'll take it too far
and they don't know i'm like we're i'm
trusting them now to do something really
bad to me that i can't see right did you
believe that there's actually a
rattlesnake there's a i knew for a fact
that that was [ __ ] there's no way
they're going to risk us trampling the
[ __ ] snake that's what that's right
actually
yeah you're not yeah preston was saying
that too he's like i knew it wasn't
gonna be the snake but it's like but it
wasn't even good
right was that the worst bit you've ever
been a part of
it was it was traumatizing and scary as
[ __ ] and yeah i i i mean yeah i guess so
how soon into filming was did that bit
happen
pretty early dude that was the first
week yeah yeah it was the first week of
that
that was the last thing i remember
driving down the highway with all the
windows rolled down after that going
i'm out of there
we did a week of filming and wow because
even so alive and so free after that
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude